I was born in rangunia in chatagram
I'm a sea fisherman I'm 58 years old and
I've been in this street for a long time
we typically head for the ocean after
buying provision for our trips but now
the prices of Essentials have doubled
because of high diesel costs
it used to cost us around sixteen
hundred dollars for all expenses for a
fishing Expedition now that's doubled
making it very difficult for us
we now have to Journey more than 24
hours to reach the fishing grounds in
the sea years ago we could find catches
within two hours of studying out but
things have changed sometimes we are
even scared to head to the deep sea
because of the nature of the weather
which is now unpredictable
we don't have any Compass or
navigational tools but I can predict the
mood of the sea and how it will be
including its depth just by traveling
few kilometers I know all this from
experience I can predict the weather
just by looking at the formation of the
clouds and the color of the sea water we
can access news and other information as
there is no mobile communication Network
when we are in the deep sea now there is
no rain during the monsoon season before
we could not even fish during the stormy
season but nowadays we can the weather
pattern has completely changed
if we could get a sonar and a GPS
navigation tools then it would be so
much easier for us to catch fish in the
deep sea but how can we purchase such
type of equipments when we were always
struggling to make ends meet
I have to support 12 family members
including my children and grandchildren
I'm the only Breadwinner in the family
and sometimes we go through rough time
especially when the fishing troller
breaks down
government is making the excuse of the
Ukraine and the Russian conflict and
using it as a pretext to increase the
full price by 50 percent in other words
taxing us unfairly by cutting into our
earnings it is like the big fish hitting
the small fries not the other way around
do you understand me